lui
no
stringe
c'è
beh quando mi hanno chiesto di buonasera
di venire a raccontare una storia io mi
sono ricordata che proprio c'è le storie
le racconto malissimo però mi sono
attaccata inizialmente al tema di questa
serata che lo spettacolo della vita
andando a leggere un po di cose
guardando anche i numeri di quelli che
sono i film e libri biografici mi sono
accorta che ogni vita di fatto uno
spettacolo se ne erano accorti già tutti
prima di me però mi sembra un diritto
proprio di quelli inviolabili il fatto
che ognuno di noi possa auspicare ad
avere una vita che qualcun altro avrà
voglia di raccontare è anche come se
fosse un po un'impresa epica quando
capita di pensare alla mia e quando
torna l'adolescenza pensavo che winona
ryder avrebbe fatto alla parte di malika
cantante famosa pacini negli anni mi
sono accorta che insomma è piantana di
me per quanto riporti meglio ma forse
non conveniva più e quindi ho iniziato a
immaginare quando ai concerti canto
ricomincio da qui che ci fosse proprio
un fermo immagine si statura essere un
po i colori e li iniziassero tutti i
titoli di coda e quindi è molto
divertente continuare a fantasticare
forse perché quando durante gli anni
della scuola guardavo film che fossero
flashdance o il documentario di
woodstock sempre mi immedesimavo è
arrivato il tempo dei documentari sulle
grandi storie le grandi vite e lì mi
sono accorta che comunque vada qualunque
cosa io faccia per quanto io potessi
essere giovane ci sarà sempre qualcuno
che storicamente più giovane di me ha
fatto qualcosa di più grandioso e allora
ho cambiato il mio punto di vista e ho
iniziato ad accorgermi che le storie più
belle le vite più interessanti sono
quelle che hanno avuto un sacco di
incidenti di percorso suo sacco di di
sfighe che però non hanno reso
come posso dire un modo per auto
commiserarsi ma semplicemente sono
diventati un'unità di misura per
considerare i picchi in altezza la
grandezza di una storia e quindi vi
porto solo questo esempio my way è una
canzone che conosciamo tutti perché
sinatra reso immortale ma perchè lo
amiamo tanto perché vorremmo
abbracciarlo nel momento in cui lui si è
visto passare davanti beatles un giorno
e si è trovato costretto a dover cantare
questa canzone per ricordare a tutti che
lui fosse è andata meno bene al signore
che si chiamava club claude françois che
ha scritto con d'habitude e che invece
ha finito la sua vita avvitando una
lampadina mentre era sotto la doccia e
che non fa si dava alla storia per
qualcosa di glorioso per cui se devo
pensare al giorno in cui qualcuno
dovesse decidere di raccontare la mia
storia
vorrei che lo facesse pensando alla
volta in cui sono entrata con il vestito
aperto in palco la volta in cui mi hanno
spedito sul palco una canzone prima e
non sapevo cosa fare o la volta in cui
il dentista perché avevo paura del
dolore ha messo chet baker per farmi
l'anestesia
a.cam suleiman
ansa